- This video is brought
to you by Bright Cellars.
(mellow music)
What's up, guys?
Michael here, and today, I'm gonna post up
in the philosophy section
of the South Park Library
and see what sort of wisdom
and truths our buds Matt
and Trey have for us in
the show's 25th season.
Now, "South Park's" been
critiquing various elements
of American politics and culture
since I was in middle school.
In fact, the best gift I
got for my 14th birthday
was the original motion picture soundtrack
to "South Park: Bigger, Longer, Uncut."
♪ You're an uncle (beep), I must say ♪
♪ Well, you (beep) your uncle yesterday ♪
Coincidentally, that
was also the first movie
I ever got caught sneaking into.
Oops.
But this season, the show's
skepticism seems more focused.
The first few episodes all
explore aspects of our culture
that can best be
understood through the lens
of an ideology called neoliberalism.
The show's cultural jabs
all point to the way
that this political and
economic ideology takes things
like public controversy, social movements,
and economic opportunities
and renders them meaningless
in the name of profit.
So what happens when we
analyze some cartoon kids
who haven't aged in a quarter century
alongside some philosophers
who are super-duper dead?
Let's find out in this "Philosopher Reacts
to 'South Park' Season 25," so far.
And spoilers ahead for
the first three episodes
of season 25 of "South Park."
But before we get into
it, I wanna tell you
about this video's
sponsor, Bright Cellars.
Bright Cellars is a
subscription wine service
that helps you discover new wines
that you'll definitely love,
and because they curate exclusive brands
plus wines from small vineyards
from all over the world,
chances are they'll introduce you to wines
you otherwise never would've
had an opportunity to try.
Now, the process starts
with a seven-question quiz
which feeds into a sophisticated algorithm
to figure out your taste profile.
For instance, I told Bright
Cellars that I like coffee,
I'm not really into sweets,
and I generally prefer reds.
And so my first box, they sent
me wines like this Merlot,
which has notes of vanilla,
a little bit of a oak
and plum flavor to it,
and as you can see, a very cool label,
and this Gewurztraminer, which is a white
that I never would've tried
before, but I really like.
Now, I'm a bit of a wine guy myself,
but there's still a lot I don't know,
and Bright Cellars'
emphasis on wine education
can help me keep learning.
Now, every bottle comes with
its own wine education card,
which includes tasting
notes, recommended pairings,
and other fun facts.
Bright Cellars is the most
convenient way to try new wines,
since they're delivered
right to your door.
And it's also a sustainable practice.
The packaging is recyclable
and plastic-free.
Plus, your monthly bottles
may include biodynamic
and sustainable varietals.
Also, Bright Cellars has some
cool new offerings this month,
including low-alcohol
varietals and sparkling wines,
so you can snag the perfect
bottle for any occasion.
Get 50% off your first six-bottle box
at brightcellars.com/wisecrack4.
That's brightcellars.com/wisecrack
and the number four
for a total of only
$55, including shipping.
Bright Cellars is the monthly wine club
that matches you with
the wine you'll love.
Get started by taking
the taste palette quiz
to see your personalized matches.
And now, back to the show.
Let's start with the first
episode of the season,
in which the kids understandably
just really wanna wear pajamas to school.
But this being "South Park" in 2022,
Matt and Trey also found some time
to rag on celebrity love
for decentralized currency.
Let's check out our first clip.
- Bruh! We can have some goddamn balls!
What does Matt Damon say
on that Bitcoin commercial?
Fortune favors the brave.
- My dad said he listened to Matt Damon
and lost all his money.
- Yes, everyone did!
- Okay, so it's worth
quickly noting the continuity
between this nod to
celebrity crypto endorsements
and the NFT plotline in the
"South Park" post-COVID special,
which we previously covered.
It's a nice hint of things to come,
as it's clear that for Matt and Trey,
the hype around crypto
simply represents one facet
of the utter emptiness at
the heart of our culture.
And okay, until a crypto bro
comes knocking at my door
with an exciting spiritual opportunity,
crypto isn't technically a religion.
But it does make me think
of Marx's infamous assertion
that "religion is the
opiate of the masses."
This line is up there with
Nietzsche's "God is dead"
in the hall of fame of
philosophical statements
that are oft quoted and rarely understood.
And that's because people,
they always ignore the words
that immediately precede Marx's assertion
that religion is the name of a new pill
produced by the Sackler family,
'cause the Sacklers are bad people
that make opiates that
are ruining our country.
Those words are, "Religion is the sigh
of the oppressed creature,
the heart of a heartless world,
and the soul of soulless conditions,"
meaning that Marx isn't some
religion-hating edgelord.
Instead, he's pointing out
that when people's lives
and social conditions suck
ass, they look for meaning
and purpose somewhere else.
And this is a theme
throughout these episodes:
folks trying to find meaning and purpose
in their otherwise-meaningless lives,
except they don't do it through religion.
They do it in much dumber ways.
- Hey, guys?
I just wanna say I'm really proud
to be a part of this office.
Wearing our pajamas shows
that we care about those schoolkids,
that we care about other people.
South Park realtors!
- [All] South Park realtors!
- Okay, so this idea that
wearing pajamas shows
that you care about kids, or
more generally that wearing
or purchasing a certain product signifies
you showing solidarity
with a marginalized group,
is an empty gesture at best,
and it shows how our soulless condition
is no longer centered around religion,
but some mix of marketing and capitalism.
Maybe it used to be important
to define yourself via
a religious affiliation,
i.e., "As a good Catholic, I
would never have premarital sex
during Lent or on Christmas."
But these days, it's more
about defining ourselves
via our consumer habits,
i.e., "I wear pajamas to
stand with the children"
or "I eat at IHOP because they
only serve pajama people."
- I'm sorry, sir, but
we aren't seating anyone
who isn't wearing their pajamas.
- And this transition from
religion to capitalism,
or more accurately capitalism
becoming the dominant system of belief,
has turned lots of social
and political issues
into matters of consumption.
As Walter Benjamin wrote
in the aptly titled
"Capitalism as Religion,"
"A religion may be
discerned in capitalism.
That is to say, capitalism
serves essentially
to allay the same anxieties,
torments, and disturbances
to which the so-called
religions offered answers."
- Since the legalization of marijuana,
communities of color,
Black and Brown Coloradans,
those most affected by
the racist war on drugs,
have now been locked out
of the wealth creation
of the industry.
(Randy yawns)
(inspiring music)
Luckily, the public is starting
to understand this unfairness,
and many people are now talking
of boycotting cannabis growers
who are only white-owned.
- Boycotting? Wait, what?
- We are seeing a healthy
and dramatic spike
in consumers who demand that
their marijuana be grown
by those who understand the
fight for social equity.
- Huh, huh, huh?
- The bottom line is this:
a completely white-owned
weed business these days
just isn't going to survive.
(dramatic music)
- Wow, what's he gonna do? Okay.
Let's get back to that fun word
we talked about before, neoliberalism.
Now, it's a slippery term to define
only because it's a bit like
explaining water to a fish,
except we're the fish
and neoliberalism is
basically everything else.
It's a political and economic ideology
that slowly wrapped its tentacles
around everything in our cultural life.
Academic David Harvey
described it like this:
"Neoliberalism is in the
first instance a theory
of political and economic
practices that proposes
that human well-being can best be advanced
by liberating individual
entrepreneurial freedoms
and skills within an
institutional framework
characterized by strong
private property rights,
free markets, and free trade."
Basically, neoliberals argue
that we are most likely
to flourish under free
market economic conditions
with limited state control,
an unrestrained market,
and strong individual
rights, which, I don't know,
maybe doesn't sound so bad.
But Harvey also argues that
neoliberalism is a class project
which is carried out by
and serves the interest
of a corporate capitalist class.
Even notably rich Catholic
daddy Pope Francis has referred
to what he calls the
dogma of neoliberal faith
to describe the system.
It's almost like it's a system
that people can put their faith into
due to the promise of a better life
but at its core is just
serving a small cadre of bros,
kind of like cryptocurrency?
And you might be thinking,
"But sir, I am no neoliberal.
I completely get how this is a system
that serves the interest of one tiny group
at the expense of the rest of us.
How dare you lump me in with it?"
But according to many scholars,
that's the wild thing about neoliberalism.
Its brilliance is its
ability to affect everything
in our culture, not just
economic and political systems.
In his book "Neoliberalism's
Demons," Adam Kotsko argues
that neoliberalism has
become a complete way of life
with a holistic worldview.
He even goes so far as
to look at neoliberalism
as a political theology,
again following Marx and Benjamin's lead.
And this holistic worldview
has penetrated the town of South Park.
This character is explaining
that the very real plight
of marginalized communities
under the war on drugs
is being addressed not through,
say, widespread exonerations
or by broadening economic
and social support systems
for folks who went to jail
for doing or selling weed.
Instead, the racism inherent
in America's drug policies
and weed industry can be
solved by spending your money
at the right businesses and
boycotting the wrong ones.
It's neoliberalism to a T.
And of course, we go on to see Randy try
to turn these systemic injustices
into a clever marketing
opportunity for his own weed brand.
- Actions speak louder than words, gang.
I guess, I guess I just
want you to think about it.
(heartfelt music)
- Wow. Dad got woke.
This right here makes me think
of one of my favorite lines
from Soren Kierkegaard,
and this comes from a short
essay called "The Present Age."
And he says this.
He says, "A revolutionary
age is an age of action.
Ours is the age of
advertisement and publicity."
It works as a description
of the social effects of neoliberalism,
in which the economic
system can absorb all types
of calls for change in
various social movements
without actually changing the system
that creates those problems,
i.e., neoliberalism will poison you
and sell you the antidote.
And this is very much
what Randy is up to here,
in which his response
to the systemic racism
at the heart of the weed
industry is to get a picture
with Tolkien's dad and
throw it up on a billboard.
And this isn't "South Park"
saying anything extreme.
Our current president once argued
that seeing interracial couples
in commercials from
major brands was evidence
that our country was less racist,
rather than, you know,
simply proof that marketing
to interracial couples is an
economically promising prospect
for big corporations.
For Kierkegaard, this comes
down to the distinction
between action and reflection
or doing the right things and
thinking the right things.
This emphasis on belief over action
complements Marx and Benjamin's ideas
about capitalism becoming
a type of religion
in which believing the right
things is more important
than changing the world
in any significant way.
It's the difference between
action and advertising.
Randy isn't reflecting on
inequality in the weed industry
to think critically about
his complicity in the system
and what actions could change it.
He just wants to feel
good by publicly agreeing
with the right ideas.
Like pajama-wearing real estate agents
performing solidarity with the kids,
Randy's performing anti-racism
for his own economic interests.
Okay, so let's check this out.
Stan went to the doctor because
he had symptoms of racism
and he wants to see if
the doctor can fix him.
- You really thought a couple
of Black people had a child
and named him Token?
Why would anyone name a Black kid Token?
You're a piece of (beep).
- No, I was just trying-
- You were just going along
with the dominant culture
of the white paradigm.
That's what you were just...
Get out of my office!
You make me sick.
- I'm sorry.
- I don't know what's
wrong with some people.
I wonder if anyone else thought
that this kid's name was Token.
Huh? Anybody?
Anyone else just assume
his name was Token?
Because that's disgusting-
- He's looking at us.
- and you are the problem.
- Doctor?
- He means us.
- I thought I told you
to get out of my office
because you seriously make me sick.
I'm gonna (beep) my
(beep) pants right now.
- Doctor, please, I
don't wanna be like this.
I'll do anything.
Just tell me what to do.
- Well, you wanna change?
Then I suggest you start
doing a lot of reading.
- Wow, the cure for racism is reading,
struggling to grapple with
the history of your racism
and your complicity in that history!
Read books.
Because this way, you can both
get access to the right ideas
while also buying more
stuff on amazon.com.
Thanks, Jeffrey Bezos.
Now, think back to that
Kierkegaard quote I just mentioned,
where rather than passion and action,
an age of reflection boils down
to advertising and publicity,
where critical thought
and social justice become
marketing campaigns,
where Burger King reminds
us that Black lives matter.
In the same essay, Kierkegaard says,
"An age without passion has no values,
and everything is transformed
into representational ideas.
There are certain remarks
and expressions which,
though true and reasonable
up to a point, are lifeless."
When a society has no real values,
even statements and ideas
that are true and valid
end up becoming pretty empty.
That about sums up this season's
thesis statement so far.
And while Kierkegaard predates
the neoliberal revolution,
this is what many argue
neoliberalism does.
It takes statements and
ideas that could be true,
sucks out their political force,
turns them into easily marketed slogans,
and sells them back to us as a product.
Real values are replaced by
toothless cultural signifiers.
- One of our fourth-grade students says
he's done a lot of work
and has grown as a person,
and he'd like to share
his journey with you.
Please welcome Stan Marsh.
- 'Sup, guys?
You know, I've done a
lot of reading lately,
and I'd like to announce that
the school has allowed me
to declare today J. R. R.
Tolkien Appreciation Day.
- Look at this little poser
with his little poser glasses.
Okay, now, to be clear,
reading books is good.
We love books.
Philosophers especially love books.
But there's reason to be
skeptical of Stan's journey,
beyond his obnoxious
pair of poser spectacles.
Now, Nietzsche said that
"the oversaturation of an age
with history seems to be
hostile and dangerous to life"
because it can "lead an
age into a dangerous mood
of irony in regard to
itself and subsequently
into the more dangerous mood of cynicism,"
a mood "through which the
forces of life are paralyzed
and at last destroyed."
Now, here, it seems
like the show is arguing
for something similar.
Now, it's pretty ironic when
neoliberal turns movements
about fundamentally changing
the world into excuses
to buy books, listen to
podcasts, or wear cool T-shirts.
And this turns from irony into cynicism
when people slowly
start to view everything
as just another marketing ploy
and just stop giving a (beep) altogether.
In reading "The Lord of the Rings"
to understand his friend Tolkien,
Stan just ends up making
things about himself
and hasn't done anything to
make Tolkien's life any better.
He's performing a new
type of social identity.
Creating a Tolkien holiday at
the school is a cynical ploy.
It's Stan's way of performing allyship
without actually changing
anything fundamental
about their school, town, or world.
Okay, so enough with symbolic pajamas and,
you know, weed companies
doing marketing and books.
Let's get to an industry with integrity,
purpose, and passion: real estate.
So this is episode three.
Let's cut over here.
There's a real estate craze
taking over South Park,
and Cartman wants to cash in.
- Ever heard of a real
estate agent, Butters?
- Well, not really.
- Yeah, well, neither had I.
So I looked it up on a bunch
of those shows and stuff.
You don't do anything.
You just look nice and hug people,
and then when someone buys or
sells a house, you make money.
- Wow. Well, that sounds like a good deal.
- It's more than a good deal, Butters.
It's (beep) legal theft.
- Okay, we're not doing a
"Real Estate Agent Reacts"
or anything here, but it's worth noting
that under neoliberalism,
rates of homeownership have plummeted,
and housing has turned into a commodity
with exponentially rising values,
values that sometimes seem
disconnected from the reality
of housing as a thing that humans need.
In the past year or so, there
have been multiple stories
about how more and more
single-family homes
are being purchased by Wall
Street investment firms
or Silicon Valley investors.
These groups grabbed
15% of available homes
in the first quarter of 2021.
That's not counting all the
homes purchased to be turned
into Airbnbs and other
short-term rental investments.
Cartman sees that something
about this system smells
like bull (beep), but
more than bull (beep),
he smells an opportunity
to exploit the bull (beep) for cash.
I can almost hear the crowds
chanting "USA! USA!" right now,
because creating an industry
around what should be a human right
and then making wild
profits off speculating
on that thing is very much
in neoliberalism's Q-zone.
- It doesn't work that way, Eric.
You aren't going to make any money.
You're just driving up the market,
and none of the deals will
make it through escrow.
- Well, we'll just see
in 30 days, won't we?
Except for some of my deals,
which have a 45-day contingency period!
- Okay, that can't be real,
'cause all the real
estate shows on TV tell me
that you make lots of
money and it's super easy.
Real estate agents, hit us in
the comments and let us know.
Now, Cartman is operating
under the conditions
of neoliberal reality, the
one that sells us on the idea
that homeownership is
the most important thing
we can do with our money,
the one that pumps out more
real estate reality shows
than we have time to watch,
and the one that tries to convince us
that a housing crisis caused
by unaffordable housing
can be solved by building more housing
for real estate agents to sell
and for Wall Street firms to buy.
Now, Cartman's mom is aware
that much of the system
is just a house of cards
waiting to fall down,
but she's still complicit within it,
and we can understand this
via French psychoanalyst Jacques Lacan,
who was very familiar with
folks like Kierkegaard,
Nietzsche, and Marx that
we've discussed so far.
He's also the Obi-Wan Kenobi
to Slavoj Zizek's Luke Skywalker.
Now, Lacan drew a
distinction between reality,
which is the product of all the symbols
and structures that make
up our social world,
and the real, which is all
the messy stuff that exists
on the other side of those
symbols and structures
and is in constant tension with reality.
In other words,
the real is what any
reality has to suppress,
and reality is constituted
via this act of repression.
It's a mind (beep) of a concept,
and Lacan himself changed its
meaning throughout his life,
but the point here is that neoliberalism,
a system pretty accurately
represented in these episodes,
creates a reality that
tries to cover up the real.
And in this season, at least so far,
Trey and Matt are pushing
some of the holy grails
of neoliberalism to the point
where we can see the
absurdity of this reality.
And while the show isn't
offering any magical solutions
to the neoliberal condition,
David Harvey has said
that "resistance to
neoliberalism can occur
in a number of different ways.
In my work I stress that the point
at which value is realized
is also a point of tension.
Value is produced in the labor process,
and this is a very important
aspect of class struggle.
But value is realized in
the market through sale,
and there's a lot of politics to that.
A lot of resistance to
capital accumulation occurs
not only on the point of production
but also through consumption
and the realization of value."
So basically, one way of
resistance is at the point
at which we make stuff, i.e., work.
But there's also an opportunity
for resistance in consumption,
meaning that we have the
ability to call bull (beep)
on some of the products and ideas
that neoliberalism sells to
us as valuable and important.
Okay, guys, I know I threw
kind of a lot at you today,
but what else do you expect
when they set me loose
on 60 minutes of adult
animation with a stack of books
and a fresh bag of coffee beans?
And if this all seems complicated,
it's because neoliberalism
is incredibly complex
and requires all the tools of philosophy,
theology, economics,
and even psychoanalysis
to really understand the system
and what the system is doing to us.
And because Matt and Trey
are cranky Gen X libertarians
and not a couple of
wine-soaked French Marxists,
they offer no underlying message
for how the world should be
in these episodes, and that's okay,
because these episodes
still make it possible
to look at some
philosophical ideas that run
right through the 19th,
20th, and 21st centuries.
And if you wanna dig deeper,
I'll leave you a reading
list in the description,
so check those out.
Now, thanks again for hanging out with us,
and please jump in the comments
and let us know what you think
about the ideas being explored
in this season of "South Park."
A huge thanks as always to our patrons
for supporting our channel,
and be sure to check out
Wisecrack's podcast as well.
Hit that subscribe button like
you're ringing a massive bell
that lets the world know that
you think all the right things
and don't forget to ring
that actual bell, either.
As always, let us know if
there's any other content
that you think warrants a
philosophical once-over.
As always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat music)
I would never have
premarital sex during Lent
or on Christmas,
'cause it's just a hot day.
You're under the mistletoe.
You've had a few eggnogs.
Mom and Dad are asleep.
You know, it's a good day for that.